hey everybody and welcome to live
streaming with Jesse a live coding with
Jesse and today we're gonna do something
different I thought we'd do some react
native so I have a react native project
that I'm nearly finished with and I
don't know that it's gonna work out how
I wanted it to so I anticipated doing
some work with Redux and react native
but here's my problem I don't know if
you can see this we make it a bit bigger
I was trying to update my packages and
it's it's just hanging I can't I tried
restarting my computer and doing it
again so I'm not sure if this is gonna
work like that but what we can do is we
can do some other work so right now I'm
running two different branches
I'm running a the master branch which
has all the same functionality but it
doesn't use Redux and then I have a
Redux branch so what we should be able
to do if if this won't work is just
switch back to the master branch and
then work off of that branch and and
everything should still work fine so
just to introduce you to what we're
working on this is a flashcard app this
is the final project for the react nano
degree from Udacity so this is how I'm
implementing that project I'm sure
there's a lot of different ways that it
could be done basically what it does is
it lets you create decks of flashcards
and then you can quiz yourself on them
so run it through quickly
so these are the decks I can click on
one of these decks and we can start the
quiz and I could answer obviously you
see the u.s. they'll need some work so I
click the first one to be correct the
second one will do in correct us to show
how the grading works basically you make
the the question and the answer and you
can toggle back and forth between the
question and the answer and then once
you're done it gives you the score in
this case we got a 50% and then you can
also add cards so this I don't think
will work right now but let's just try
to add one yeah see it's not going to
work because this branch is trying to
use redux to do this but all the redux
packages are not installed so let's
dismiss that go back and you're also
able to add a new deck this is not gonna
work most likely as well let's submit
that oh you know what I don't think I
hope that went up to redux yet so that
didn't throw an error yet but that's how
it's supposed to work all right yeah
this still is not working so let's just
cancel that for now and switch over to
our other branch
okay I do want to probably have to
restart this
there we go okay let's run yarn quickly
in this branch I'd like to at least test
to see if it was something I was trying
to do on the branch or if it's something
wrong with this computer we'll let that
go for a minute just to see see what's
going on but let's check out a little
bit of the code they make this a bit
bigger
and let me say hey to everyone in the
live chat before we start to put it it's
uh Nance and says you broke it yes I
somehow I broke the Arne I don't I don't
know what I did
alright see that's not that's still not
working so let's just quit that and
let's refresh
hmm maybe I'll restart the server this
actually the first time I've tried to
run this on this computer I've been
developing this on my my laptop so it's
probably why I'm having problems I
didn't it didn't allow enough time
before the stream to test everything out
but here's some of the code that we're
working with and I guess since we
haven't ever worked with react native on
this stream I'll do a little intro it's
going to be really familiar if you're if
you've been watching what we're doing
with react but there are a few
differences so I'm just going to run
through the differences quickly just to
make it a little bit easier to to
understand what's going on and why we
had to do things a little differently
let's see dragon hunter said am I too
late no no I haven't said yeah and
nobody's too late yet we haven't haven't
really started anything let's see
yes I am using using Adam okay heart
should also asked about your PR Arshad
I'm testing that pool request
so I've downloaded it to a different
branch and I'm testing it I think I
ended up using the service that you
recommended the M lab setting up a
MongoDB database and that was all
working I think my problem still is the
email thing
so the was a email mail trap for some
reason it still doesn't work I think you
had mentioned something about possibly
the port's being blocked by my network
I'm thinking that that's the problem
because I've had issues before with
ports in the past so I know the the
ports are kind of on lockdown here so
what I'm gonna do and this is why I
decided not to livestream that because
I'm not going to try to do any work on
that project until I'm gonna go home on
my home network where I have more
control over what ports or blocks I'm
gonna test everything out there
hopefully it all works out then and then
if it works out I'll merge it all just
gonna have to come up with some other
way to do testing I guess from you know
from work from my office so anyway
that's why I haven't merged yet and
that's why we're not working on it right
now so hopefully at least don't know if
it still doesn't work at home then maybe
it's something else but from everything
that I've tried doing with it it's it's
probably a port thing so I'll have more
info about that tomorrow
alright so let me go no no beer it so I
forget to shave yeah
I have not Harsha is asking change
support 25 I changed I tried port 25 I
tried port for something whatever the
other one you recommended was I tried
all this porch nothing worked so yes
I'll just I'll try it out at home
Trieste if I'm drunk I am NOT drunk now
I haven't been any alcohol today
actually for a while I don't remember
the last time I drank okay let's let me
start my timer and
okay so we're just going to go over some
code first and then maybe we'll try to
do some updates
maybe with with the UI so sorry about
the misleading title really did want to
work with with redux but and so I figure
out what's going on with yarn we could
do work with redux and reasonably expect
that it would do what we want it to do
but I have no way to test it so let's
check this out first of all well we'll
start at the beginning here with our app
dot J's file obviously you know we make
this a bit bigger for you all so the
setup for package.json is is actually
should look pretty similar to any other
react project and then I've added in our
standard linting that we've been using
on all our projects with with prettier
and standard Jass you notice a little
bit something's a little different
instead of react strips we have react
native scripts right so everything is is
going to say you know react native
instead we're using expo which it brings
in expo does a lot of stuff you'll see
us bringing in some components and
things from expo we're importing it in
various parts of our app it also comes
with an app that you can download and
then allows you to test out the app on
your phone and debug and everything you
know right there so let's see all right
so not a lot going on with the
package.json let's check out our app j/s
okay so we're bringing in you know react
just like normal we have let's go over
some of the navigation because now the
navigation is probably one of the
biggest differences between react and
back native that I've dealt with so far
so if you notice we're bringing in we're
not using react router we're using react
navigation we're bringing in a tab
navigator and a stack navigator so the
the navigation is definitely see where
I'm pulling this in okay so here's the
the first part I have a tab navigator
and now this obviously these are the
tabs at the top or if if you're on
Android the tabs are at the top if
you're on iOS the tabs at the bottom one
of the cool things about react native is
the there are some standard components
that get rendered differently based on
whether you're on iOS or Android so
it'll use like the native styling
options for those which is really cool
you don't have to worry about doing that
yourself so in this case we added some
some tabs we have a list view tab and a
deck view tab this is really
straightforward right we have our screen
right this is the label tab our label
this is what the user will see and then
we say what component is going to render
so you can see all our views over here
our react components so we just tell the
Navigator what component to display as
the view when you click on that
particular tab so super easy notice we
do import this so it's very similar to
react router in those terms but we have
we also have some options so you can
style your tab bar okay just your basic
basic options colors and things like
that but then we also have the stack
navigator and think of the stack
navigator like if you were to click on
buttons within the app you wouldn't want
the views to change right but you don't
want every single view to be
on your tabs that you would have to
weigh too many tabs so this is where all
the rest of them the rest will come into
play so we're bringing in the tabs here
so we're actually so we've we've named
this tab navigator tabs right we saved
it to that constant so we're pulling all
of this in and then in addition to that
we're adding a screen for what we call
it work for a deck view our new question
view our quiz view and you saw all those
views when we did the demo a few minutes
ago right so that's how navigation works
so some elements are familiar but that
was definitely something I had to grab
my head around you know to understand I
was coming from you know browser mode
using you know react router so a little
bit different for that let's see as far
as this page is concerned I think that's
all you don't want to go over maybe this
since it's this here we'll talk about
this we have this style sheet dot create
and you'll notice I guess it's hard to
see on this base we'll go to another
page here so maybe it's a little bit
more obvious where's your stuff there we
go
so we're using style sheet create we
don't have to do it this way but there's
a performance improvement if you add
your Styles in like this and then you
know this is just a JavaScript object
and then we can put it in here so on our
view we have style
we just have style style container so
then everything under container is
applied to this component right you'll
notice there are no there's no
indication of pixels or anything like
that everything in react native is just
just straight numbers okay so they don't
you know we don't have like VH or pixels
or eeehm
whatever you want to will you normally
use in the browser obviously we're still
doing since this is a JavaScript object
we're camel casing everything we're
actually importing colors so we have a
color CAS file and we're just bringing
in the colors from there so we have
purple and white coming in let's see I
have just some some test data up here so
this will actually be gone in the the
production version of this app but I
needed some test data to work on before
I had everything set up and working
okay we're using async storage instead
of local storage so there isn't local
storage on your your device the
equivalent would be async storage
depending on your device whether it's
iOS or Android the database that's
holding that in the background will be
different but you don't have to worry
about that a sink storage takes care of
all that and you have a simple API to
use that so for now it's just get item
right so we're safe everything is just
saved as key value pairs so all of our
our decks are saved with under the key
decks right and then so in this
particular case we're just getting
everything all of them and then we're
just looping through them all let's see
there's oh okay the only other
difference you'll see we don't have divs
or P tags right we have views so instead
of a div you're probably going to want
to use view wherever you would normally
use a div and instead of a P tag you
want to use text that's just in general
so you would never just have text right
normally you could have just text inside
of a view that isn't wrapped in a
component but you can't do that in react
native you have to have any text wrapped
inside of a text tag so that's that's
probably the other really big difference
so
probably the way you do routing and then
the views and text instead of divs and P
tags probably the biggest biggest
differences I guess I could show on let
me show one that has input so you can
see with the inputs it's actually not
that it's not that different from what
you would normally see the cool thing
though is we don't have to worry as much
about styling inputs so by default
depending on what you're using you get
that default device style so so that's
kind of nice you can of course style it
however you want but if you if you
didn't want to worry about that you get
default styling which is cool all right
so let's let's actually do some some
coding with this and let me see how much
time I have I do want to answer
questions I know I see the live chat is
a lot going on in there right now so I
will as soon as this pommeroy time is up
I'll go and answer some questions and
then we'll see how much time we have I
have a meeting in about an hour
so I can't go any longer than that and I
need to get I need to get some data
ready for the meeting so probably need
to end no later than like 45 minutes
from now okay
looks like my app froze on my
my device so I'm gonna restart it so we
can actually see what's going on well
that's well that's working let's go back
over here and we
let's see okay here we go all right so
it's back we're back here let's um let's
take a look at the UI and see where we
could have some improvements here one
thing that I've noticed probably could
be improvement is uh we need these
titles need to be bigger and uniform
throughout right now they're not uniform
throughout so we can we also need that
let's add a card because a couple of
cards so that we can see the UI so that
should be good but your notice right now
here's my biggest problem the UI doesn't
automatically update when you add a card
so right now the data is there so the
data for those two new cards that we
just put in is there in a sink storage
so but it's not reflected yet so what
I'd have to do then is reload and when
we reload you'll see it's it'll be
reflected see so now we have our two
cards okay so now we can see our quiz
all right so we have our question and
answer and we have this is the second
question right so so that works now but
what I need to have happen and this is
why I was starting to implement Redux I
mean also it's the data is a little bit
cleaner with Redux anyway but I wanted
to try to get that automatic refresh but
since we can't really get Redux working
right now we're gonna put that on hold
and instead we're going to work a little
bit on the UI so here's what I'd like to
do these buttons are way too big in
proportion to the other text on the page
so the text inside the buttons as well
as the title and everything so let's
just do some style
and lesson react native the stylings not
it's not that different but it is a
little bit odd to get used to a unitless
styling okay so we're we knew we're deck
view okay so we're in our deck view and
let's go down to our styles and let's
check out our font size I think we can
definitely for our title we can double
that font size and I think that'll still
look look pretty good our number I think
the numbers fine for right now that's
that this area right here and you can
see we've already seen since we have my
device is connected to my computer right
now and so it's Auto refreshing every
time we change something which is nice
so this is a lot nicer size I think I'll
stick with that for now and let's maybe
adjust these a bit I want to keep the
buttons large enough so that they can
comfortably be clicked by users even if
the user happens to have a large thumb
so I'm hesitant to make the buttons any
smaller but I would like to make the
proportions a bit nicer so let's check
out our button let's see how we have
this here so our text let's make another
another we're gonna it only this works
like a class but you know what I'm
saying it's not really a class since
this is just a JavaScript object that
we're gonna call this button text and
I call this button text I guess I don't
have I don't have space between these
and let's make the button text let's see
what 20 looks like I think it might be a
bit too big but we're gonna try it out
so we'll go font size 20 and we'll leave
the color alone right now let's see what
this looks like
oops we didn't put it I didn't apply it
so here's what we need to do and that's
not a comma so let's take this this text
we're actually going to use we're going
to apply it to both of these and we need
to add style and let's go with styles
dot button text
okay now we'll save that and see how it
looks okay not bad not bad so you can
see this I think that that font size is
more appropriate given the size of our
buttons okay not bad I still don't
really love the proportions though oh it
would probably better if we had a title
of this deck that it was more reasonable
so let's add a deck let's see okay
that's a little bit bigger I'm gonna
submit that and once again we actually
have to manually reload this to get it
to show up here we go here's our test
deck okay this is not bad not bad
okay let's let's check out our whoops Oh
interesting
I have to do something like that maybe
if there are no cards then let's disable
that start quiz how about that let's add
that in right now because you know we
don't really want that behavior so I
don't know if you saw that but when I
click start quiz since there's no cards
that automatically takes me to the score
screen and obviously we can't get a
score if there are no cards so let's
change that so right now on that button
to start the quiz we have on press and
then we navigate to the quiz but what we
want to do instead is check first to see
if there are any cards and if there
aren't cards we don't want to navigate
so let's remove this yeah let's remove
this and we're going to bring it up here
that's
and the navigation so I don't know about
you but before I started react native I
was afraid that it would just be way you
know just so much more different that I
wouldn't I wouldn't be able to to catch
on very quickly but you could see I mean
this is very much like what we what
we're used to so let's see we're gonna
need to put let's let's make this so
that it can handle our clicks on both
buttons so what we need to bring in then
is the view and the deck and so here
what we can bring in there is
oops I don't know why get rid of that
what did I call that handle navigation
navigation and what did we call it we
quiz so that you was quiz and then we
did bring in where did we get that from
oh okay
we're already bringing in deck here so
okay and let's copy this
and for this one we're going to bring in
new question
so if you notice here normally we would
put an on click here for a button but
it's it's on press for react native
which makes sense we're not not clicking
you know this is all touchscreen alright
let's see question you need to put in
view and then yeah this should be fine
the way it is let's save that and we'll
click it
let's see if it works
whoops no she's not the fine
whoops I didn't say
all right let's chat again my addition
is not a function
what did I do wrong okay now it's
working all right great
so it's working and it looks like it's
taking us to the right place and it's
passing the data we can double-check
that it's faster data by going to
something actually does have data yeah
and those are the right question
oops sorry I didn't realize I didn't
know this on the screen I'll do this
again this we can see this one it is
passing the right card data and it's
obviously going to the right spot so now
that we've implemented that we can say
at least for this on press so we're
gonna say if my shirts yes we're gonna
say if deck questions dot length is
greater than zero
okay I've had questions length greater
than zero
I didn't want to deck all right let's
see if I work no we're ready
okay I'm getting an error be so against
something
my
whoops let's try to make this irregular
otherwise
no questions
all right let's make this
oops
all right so basically what I want to do
with this there's no questions is
indicate to the user that they need to
add a question so for right now
right now that's gonna be a console.log
which obviously isn't gonna help the
user that much on a device but at least
this will remind me what I intend to do
with this in case we don't get get to it
during the stream all right so my timer
is up so let me set my five-minute timer
and oh there we go
getting more useful feedback here that's
my old code
very uh there we go okay so that I keep
forgetting you can't see my screen okay
so I'm on this test deck now and I'm
hitting the start quiz button you can
see that feedback there and it's not
doing anything but if we go to our other
deck where we do have cards we hit start
quiz and it does work so that's what
we've that's what we've done here is
just made sure that you can't start the
quiz unless there are actually cards so
the next step which we may or may not do
on this dream would be to add some sort
of visual feedback to the user to remind
them that you need to add a card first
okay so let me go let me restart that
five-minute timer since I went back and
did some work let's see I'm gonna go
through mmm
questions alright let me go through the
question just see what's here we may or
may not do another Pomodoro session
since I do have a meeting coming up soon
all right so I'm gonna scroll up and try
to work my way down through as many
questions as I can
[Music]
oops you guys can see that but or not
also forgot to mention this but there's
a live stream going on now from the
chrome Developers Conference
so if check that out I was watching it a
little bit of it earlier and some
interesting stuff so I don't know what
the times are for everything that I
think is going on pretty much all day
today
paka says i'm trying to master react
before going on redux what do you guys
think I don't know that you need to
master react before getting to before
getting to Redux yeah I mean if you end
up working on a project project where it
makes sense to use Redux
I'd say go for it because there are
definitely some times where Redux is
going to help you significantly and
keeping your app keeping the dataflow on
your app more sensible so if you're
building absolute that they don't really
need it then don't worry about it but
it's a good thing to know so I mean it's
not the only option either right there
there are other options for handling
your data other than Redux so you may
not need to use Redux you could go with
what it mob X which I have not used yet
but in general when a question is like
do I need to master this before doing
this my answer is almost always no like
you don't need to just learn learn what
you need to do for that whatever makes
the most sense for your projects and
it's not it's not really an either/or
thing with these different technologies
you can learn them both as you go
alright hey Sebastian says update yarn
ok cool why I did not try to update yarn
yet so I would do that to try to fix my
my issues with this dragon on just said
a broken yarn still faster than NTM not
in this case although I've heard the
newer versions of NPM are pretty fast
too I haven't seen data as to which
one's faster but I think it's better
ok Harshit says clean clean the cache
and yarn ok I want to try that
three thinks I sound drunk on the stream
so do I actually sound drunk on the
stream I don't know you know how it is
when you hear your own voice recorded it
always sounds weird to you so my voice
always sounds weird I'm not a good judge
I guess
okay actually let me try this now since
we'll try to clean that out and see if
that will work
Harshit says which version of yarn are
you using one per point one cause
problems for me yeah you know what I
think I'm using a later version of yarn
on my laptop because I just I recently
upgraded iron on my laptop like sometime
within the last two weeks or so so I'm
definitely using an older version here
so I mean let's give it a shot
see maybe maybe something will happen
here but okay see Z ohm boy says why do
you use Pomodoro app what are the
benefits
Harshit mentions it helps to manage time
and track work yeah definitely so in
this case on the stream I also use it to
help me to break up the stream and
remember to stop coding and check out
the live chat answer some questions and
then also to remember to stop answering
questions go back to the live chat but I
do use it even when I'm not streaming
and it does help it helps break up the
work into manageable chunks keep me on
track and keep me taking regular breaks
because often it's it's easy for me at
least to keep working on a problem and
I'm stuck and I keep trying things and
trying things and it doesn't work but if
I step back and take a break even if
it's just for a few minutes for some
reason my brain just it needs that
little break and then when I come back
to it I can i often either solve the
problem or I realize you know what there
are better things for me to do right now
this isn't really a main issue you know
I may have been working really hard on
some side thing that wasn't essential
for the product to launch so I like that
little break it really helps I find I'm
a lot more productive when I'm using the
Pomodoro timer let's see well based on
the amount of questions I'm seeing in
the live chat I think I should try to
get through the questions now and not
hey all right you got through it all
awesome okay so if you didn't see what
just happened there if any of you ever
run into a similar problem where yarn
just is hanging and not working try yarn
cache clean as your command
Harshit just mentioned that and thank
you for that advice and that worked for
me so everything installed now I would
want to double check and test this on
the other branch as well but we saw I
was having the problem on both branches
so since it worked on this branch I'm
assuming that'll work on the other
branch I'm not going to test it right
now because we still have changes here
that I want to commit first anyway so
cool
that'll work so maybe I would actually
like to have everything finished and
turn this project in today so I don't
know if we'll work on this more on the
stream it depends on whether or not my
project passes the review so we'll see
if it doesn't pass and I have more work
to do maybe we'll do another stream on
this otherwise I'll have to implement
all the Redux stuff on my own but in any
case whenever the project passes then I
can I can show you on the ship might not
do a whole stream about it but I can
show you the finished product and of
course it's on my github profile so you
can check out the code whenever you want
all right so let me just run through the
rest of these questions here let's see
okay dragon hunter says set in 8vd with
android studio why Expo I'm not sure
about the first part of that statement
but it why use Expo instead of Android
studio I'm using Expo because that's how
so within the Udacity course that's how
we were taught to do app development so
I could use Android studio but but this
was just the the quickest way to get
everything set up
alright see the whisper in your ears
says that's that's actually the name
says hey let me ask you I've been trying
to choose full stack frame work and
everything came down to meteor or sales
apparently there is nothing more
dominant these days but people say
meteor is dead now
Harshit says meteor is not that dead
dragon hunter says if pearl is not dead
yet then nothing is that I guess the
whisper in the ears is kind of weird
because meteor has so many stars in
github so let's see yet to be honest
with you I've seen really cool things
done with meteor I don't know about
numbers as far as how how many people
still use meteor if it's if it is dying
I don't really know but from what I've
seen built with meteor it's it it was
certainly very capable so generally I
don't really do full stack stuff here
I'm more front-end although we do
include some back-end stuff when we need
to so I don't know that I'm the best
person to give you advice on and it's
our framework to choose
let's see but maybe if somebody here
watching is
stack or has an opinion that way you
know please share that in the live chat
okay all right sory says guys you're
wasting your time this is not realistic
go elsewhere good luck
okay so not sure what would I did that
upset three but I guess the streams not
for everybody
see I'm not sure what he means by
realistic I mean this this actually
really is a project that I'm doing so I
it's realistic for me this is how I work
so let's see a harsh it says in response
I have already cloned and tested the app
yesterday so I'm not wasting my time
let's see
okay so the whisper New Year's is saying
it's still talking about the question of
a full-stack framework is saying
JavaScript doesn't have a dominant stack
like like laravel for PHP Harshit says
use pug with express it's really
powerful okay Harshit says it gives
flexibility
okay so I'm not gonna read everything
but there's a debate here about whether
or not Express is capable in the same
way as a full-stack framework is a
dominant framework so the debate seems
to be from well you can add things to
Express to basically do everything that
you want it allows a lot of flexibility
like that but on the other hand it's not
like ready to go you know right off the
bat to do everything you need so let's
see
somebody's mentions happy use H API it's
a framework I've never used that so I
can't comment on it
shree mentions do you know what async
async' EO is that a sink that supposed
to be a sink I don't really know
no I'm I'm not I'm not aware of what a
sink EO is Jamal says is this the
Udacity project yes it is the Udacity
project so it's it's project three of
that react nano degree for Udacity so
the it's the final project so as soon as
I'm done with this and it gets accepted
then I'm officially done with the nano
degree and and I passed so really
excited if you all been watching you
know like it's been taking up a lot of
my time doing the the nano degree so I
learned a lot through this but I'm
definitely excited to not spend all my
my Saturdays and doing this I'd much
rather to have some time to spend with
the kids and I'm sure they would rather
let me spend time with them as well
let's see
[Music]
[Music]
all right sir II said you really can't
do this any more than five minutes I'm
not sure what I was doing at the time
when when you said that tree so I guess
if you could elaborate maybe I'll answer
but I can't when was that 153 yeah I'm
not sure what I was working on at that
time sure he also says you can't do it
yeah I don't remember what I was working
on at the time hard should ask if I need
a PR in this project two already cloned
and tested it actually hard should I
appreciate the offer but I don't feel
comfortable taking any PRS for this
project since it is for a course so I
need to I need to do it all myself since
it's for course otherwise as you all
know I'm perfectly you know happy to
collaborate on projects I'm not I'm not
one that needs all the control over
things I realized that you all bring a
lot of expertise to the table so I'm
quick to admit whenever I need to take
the help of someone else but in this
case since it is for a class and I'm
being graded in a sense on this I'm
gonna have to figure it out on my own
but again thanks for the offer I
appreciate that and then certainly after
I turn it in if we want to keep working
on this I'm definitely open for that if
we want to try to make it better and
actually launch it as an app that's cool
too I think I'll probably still work on
it I'd like to maybe have my kids be
able to use it to help them study so
that's something I'm definitely
definitely open to
rook says those unitless CSS values are
pixels can you use REM as well I'm not
sure if they're exactly pixels
I don't recall in that part of the
course when they explained that I don't
recall exactly what they are so I don't
know maybe somebody knows but I don't
know if they translate exactly to what
what pixels would be let's say like if
you are in a browser on a mobile device
I don't think you can't so ATS also
about using a.m. or REM I don't think
you can use any units I actually haven't
tried but I'm pretty sure that you
you're not supposed to use units with
that so if you didn't if you don't
remember that part it when we're doing
the CSS or the styles for in react
native there are no units so normally
you would see pixels or EMS or something
here but we don't use units
all right harsh it says I guess the unit
is relative to device yeah I think
that's how it works it all depends on
the I guess the device pixel ratio well
and that I don't know there it's hard to
talk about it without a unit right but I
think it does depend on the the
resolution of the screen and size of the
screen let's see harsh that says hey
Jessie did you hear about Adam IDE check
out Adam that I oh yeah actually I I saw
something about the Adam IDE I may end
up checking out at some point
so we'll see maybe I'll test it out we
could use on a stream or something when
I first heard about it I thought I
didn't really need any of that
functionality but it would still be cool
maybe to take a look at and just just to
show everyone John Hanson says the start
quiz button looks wider odd yeah let me
reload see if it'll work
there we go yeah let's check that out
actually you're right to start quiz
button does look wider interesting I'll
have to check that out later on to see
if it if it really is wider I mean
there's there's yeah it is odd yeah I
definitely want them to be the same I
don't want one to be wider than the
other I may change how these buttons
look as well right now at this point I'm
not as worried about the Styles because
I just need to get this turned in before
the deadline so unfortunately it's not
gonna look awesome
but I just need to fit all the project
requirements so I can always style it
later on
save some debate about between view and
reacts which I'm kind of skipping over a
bit to look for more questions okay
Blake says if I learned react what I
also know almost all of react native
well it depends on how much you mean by
almost all you would know a lot you
would know a lot of it so the concepts
are the same right so the idea that you
have these components that get rendered
into something else right that's that's
entirely the same but in terms of like
specifically how you do things right
there are some differences but I mean I
pointed out to me at least the big
differences for me and learning it and
you see they weren't really that big of
a deal so I didn't think it was that big
of a stretch to move from react to react
native okay now I don't know if I went
even deeper and try to do something more
complex than just a flash card app maybe
I would run into some more issues but I
think going for me at least going from
not using react to do web development to
using react was a much harder transition
than transitioning from react to react
native so that was just my experience
but it just didn't seem that hard to
translate the concepts into building
something you know for phone than doing
web development
so Blake s so what do you think I should
learn yes so Blake I think to be honest
with you it depends on what your goals
are for for learning right
I mean learn whatever you enjoy you know
or learn what you need to do for the
projects that you're doing but react
right now is growing it's continuing to
grow there are a lot of react jobs the
pay-for react developers is nice so if
you enjoy working with react I said go
for it I mean are there alternatives
that are popular yeah there are
alternatives that are popular but I I
just I see react more and more in job
listings so if your goal is to get a job
doing this type of thing then you know
it would be I don't think it would be
wrong to go with react but it's just a
pow mean if you check out to you and you
really like you there are jobs for view
developers if you check out angular and
you love that then they're still you
know there are a lot of jobs for that so
definitely test out different things but
I think you'd be fine if you did want to
go with react I think you'd be fine from
a from the standpoint of having
marketable skills
all right I got to keep an eye on the
time here okay so I'm good probably
about like 10 more minutes I'm going to
try to get through the rest of these
questions I think I can do it
Blake asks well he's asking Harshit
would you agree that there's bigger
support base and react our [ __ ] says yes
yeah I would agree as well John Hanson
says does one need to use native if a
create react app has a responsive layout
or does this all go further than how
react deliver is different from desktop
to Android iOS etc Mobile portable apps
yes
yeah so you could potentially do like in
one of our previous projects we use
create react app just for a regular
react app and then we were able to save
it to our desktop and run it and it
looked a lot like a native app but it
really wasn't a native app right so to
get more of the benefits of a native app
you go with react native right so in a
if you're doing just a regular react app
you could make it seem like it was a
native app but really it wouldn't be the
underlying code is still JavaScript HTML
CSS when you're using react native the
underlying code becomes native code for
that device so depending on where your
iOS or Android you know it's different
but we're no longer talking about just
HTML CSS JavaScript that's what you see
when you develop but what actually ends
up getting delivered to the device is
the native code
so there's definitely under the hood
there's a big difference but then you
also have access to more more on the
device so I know there's the support is
pretty good for let's say a browser like
Chrome to access a lot of things on the
device but it's never going to be as
and I shouldn't say never but it's it's
not as good released now in terms of
having direct access to all the
functions on a device and I imagine
there's definitely some performance
improvements as well when you could do
it like that so if you if your goal is
to build an app that people can download
from an app store then definitely use
react native if you're not that worried
about that and it's something that would
make more sense to be a website that
could potentially also act like like an
app you know progressive web app then
you know you could just use normal react
let's see alright so blake link
something i'm not gonna have time to
read through this but the question the
the link for the question is react je s
vs. JS versus static what should I do
so I'm gonna unfortunately I think if I
want to be done in time let's let me
save that and if I get through the rest
of the live chat maybe I'll try to come
back to it if I have time
Brooke says in that logical and error
try wrapping the arrow function in
parentheses okay that must have been we
were getting errors there so as we
worked it out sorry I didn't see that
when I was working on it there okay
thanks thanks for helping that Roger
says maybe you should make a video about
how to keep up with your videos maybe I
will do you all think that I need to do
that have some instructions there are
quite a few videos now and some are
better than others I mean I'm I'm not
gonna lie you all are very nice about it
but I know there's some times when I
have a goal for a stream and it just
doesn't happen and it's just a failure
for the most part other times we get a
lot of stuff done and it's really cool
but I mean that's what it's supposed to
be right the goal of the stream isn't
like let's get as much done as possible
let's let's see what it's like for
somebody to get through their work and
sometimes fail all right rich Rishabh
says hey man pretty excited for the
stream working on it from last 8 months
really excited to see if I missed
something as per standards cool awesome
five Huff says good morning hey how's it
going rishabh says I've been writing
services on meteor and consuming
services with react native it's great
for middle level apps alright that's
cool that's cool let's I'm glad to hear
you have some experience with react
native so maybe for future projects when
we use it you'll be a great resource for
us then let's see and and we'll glue
wopo sorry if I'm mispronouncing your
name but I know Lupo says for the pages
using the stack navigator do you have to
import stack navigator from react native
navigation another quick walkthrough on
how the screen Navigator works would be
cool okay yeah no problem let's check
out that navigator again so I'm going to
go back into app touch ass and let's
check out so right now we're importing
tab navigator and stack navigator from
react navigation and then what we will
we have or - so here's our main
navigator alright well we have a home
screen we have a deck new question and
quiz yes we base we just have four views
then for home we're actually importing a
whole nother navigator because we want
the home view to have tabs so in that
case we've created another navigator the
tab navigator and within tab navigator
we have two views list view deck whew
alright so we have four main views and
then we have this home screen actually
is split up into two two different parts
so I guess that's what five in total so
that's how we you know we bring that in
and now that we've done this alright and
we've we've linked all this up here in
app j/s which is our route component now
when we go into something like let's go
to list view because that's home when we
go into this view
we can do navigation so we can actually
do this so we have this on press this
props navigation navigate deck right so
we can navigate right to that view
called deck which we added in here so
the view is called deck and it goes to
the screen the component of deck view
and and for all of our sub components we
can do that we can just run that
navigate this props navigation navigate
and go right there and this isn't all we
can do there are a lot of other options
for for what you can do with a navigator
but this is the one that I'm using most
often potentially this might be the only
way that I'm doing things because the
apps pretty simple
and then I happen to be passing some
data along as well which is nice to be
able to do that but that's optional so
hopefully that that helps I can show you
I guess the touch as well so am i
bringing this in
this times no that's my status bar then
I guess it's enlist you
I guess it just gets added in I was
looking to see if there was someplace
where we had to add in the tabs but I
don't think we did so when we when we
choose tab navigator and we say what we
want each one to be so we want it to
display as decks and new deck and then
we give it some options
just for styling then automatically on
the home the home screen it just adds
those tabs and it knows what views what
components from here we've given it the
list view new deck for you so you don't
actually have to plug that in anywhere
it's just it's it's there let's go back
to one of those views as you can see so
there we go there's our tabs so
hopefully that that helped to help
understand that like I mean that's like
just a really simple thing it took me a
while to read through documentation and
watch the videos and figure out how that
all works together so if anyone is
having trouble getting that after my
very quick explanation don't worry about
it I definitely needed a little while
for that all to sink in in the process
Thiago says our ask do you think the
react nanodegree is a good idea are you
enjoying it I am enjoying it so like I
said I'm just I'm busy so I'm not
enjoying having to spend all that time
away from my family but I've learned a
lot from it so it's pushed me to do
things that I probably would not have
pushed myself to do so I I like it I
think it was worth it I wish I paid the
full price for the course and then a few
weeks later they had a sale for Half
Price
so my only regret is that I didn't wait
for the sale and get it for Half Price
but otherwise it's been great I
especially really like
the code reviews so when you turn in a
project it gets reviewed by someone and
they go through and let you know what
you could have done better or if you
didn't meet some of the requirements and
they give you suggestions so that was
really helpful because I don't usually
have people reviewing my code and so
that was helpful and that really pushed
me you know to go back and say no do it
again that's not the best way you could
have done it and so yeah so I definitely
learned a lot I've come a long way
between these streams and the help that
you are giving me and the react
nanodegree I learned quite a bit in
these last you know a few months of
doing this it's I'm pretty amazed at how
far I've come you know in terms of my
abilities with react in just that short
amount of time
so I think I'll end up doing a video
like a review of my thoughts on the
course when I'm done with it
so maybe sometime in November I'll be
able to make that and I'll put that on
my my youtube channel and just kind of
go through what I what I thought but as
of right now I say it was worth it oh
cool Alexander says the in terms of the
pixels they are di P density independent
pixels awesome
whoo I figured that there was there was
some explanation for it but thanks for
that so the the unitless let's see were
not so the unitless values here that
we're using for react native are
actually device independent pixels was
that it density independent pixel sorry
I'm setup density independent pixels
let's see which table uh
alright mujtaba
sorry if I'm mispronouncing Apple each
table says Jesus was sent by God to
teach people teaching is like being a
prophet but people do never appreciate
many things in life though
if the knowledge is free of charge
great yeah actually unfortunately you're
right if if something's free people do
usually take it for granted and don't
appreciate it quite as much so it's
great that free code camp is free but
sometimes just in talking to people no
one's come out and said it but
occasionally I get the feeling that
sometimes people don't take free code
camp as seriously as some of the other
people that teach code for profit you
know that that cost money when I think
what we have is free code camp is really
high-quality and it's it's amazing and
I'm allowed to talk about my stream I
mean sometimes my stream is a mess but
the other people that that do videos and
that work on the free code camp website
and the forum you know and all the
different things that free code camp has
going on it's great quality it's amazing
what we've been able to do just with
volunteers and keep it all completely
free of charge so it is really good and
I hope people realize that in this case
free does not mean that it's somehow
below the quality of other things I mean
I I think free code camp in in many
cases is a better quality than some of
the paid paid courses that I've taken
and that I've seen so anyway thanks for
that much table I appreciate you saying
that
let's see Saucon says redux ugh it
doesn't make sense to me the generator
thing looks so high-level stuff would
you use thunks saga observer or anything
else I've used thunk so thunks pretty
simple I've used it I have not had
experience with saga yet so I I'll
probably end up working with it at some
point I just kind of like to know what
it's like and what the differences
between thunk and saga but if you're
having trouble with saga I would check
out funk it seemed it's really simple to
use at least in my experience it's
I should ask what mirroring software I'm
using it's called
visor let me see if I can bring it up so
yeah I don't know if you can see that
now you can't see that on the bottom
uh-huh because my my thing some way let
me move this oops let me move this you
can see a little bit so visor that's the
icon there I guess that's really small
but it's it's called it's what is it V Y
SOR visor
let's see let me see the time oh man I
got a rep let me go really quickly
through the rest of the live chat and
then I got a go to my meeting I can't be
late to this meeting the head of my
department is going to be in this one
and my boss will be in it so definitely
got to finish up quickly here so I'm
gonna skip the comments so sorry I won't
be able to read all the comments but I
do want to get to the questions Schlow
bird says how do I get an overview of
all the JavaScript frameworks I just use
basic js4 now and I don't know which
with with which frameworks I should
start
I don't program for a living I don't
know that there's a resource off the top
of my head I don't know a resource that
good there's an overview I imagine it
probably exists somewhere so I'll tell
you what send me a message on Twitter or
something and then I'll send if I can
find something I'll send it to you if I
had more time in the stream I try to
look something up right now so sorry
about that but coming back for another
stream or send me a message or something
on Twitter and I'll try to help you out
as best I can
oh cool harsh it says there's a material
design framework for react native so
it's react native material design github
I Oh awesome that sounds really cool
like I said I'm not gonna do it now
because I need to turn this in the
deadlines almost here but after I turn
it in if I do some extra work I
I may end up using that okay all right
hard should I see what you're saying
about the SendGrid keys I'll test that
out later on maybe after my meeting
okay harsh it's asking about how to find
freelance work yeah so like I don't have
time to answer right now cuz I gotta go
to my meeting but hard [ __ ] ask me that
send me a message on Twitter or ask me
in tomorrow stream and we can go over
that in more depth I do have some advice
I used to freelance for a few for like
three years so I definitely have some
advice on that so I'm happy to help you
out with that
world's s what's the disadvantage of PHP
I don't work that much with PHP but one
thing that I've noticed with PHP that I
don't really like and I don't I haven't
that looked at a lot but I have a
co-worker that's dealt with it a lot and
it's been a problem is the different
versions of PHP don't always work well
together so he's worked on some legacy
projects where he can't upgrade to newer
versions of things because of issues
with different PHP versions supporting
different things so it's kind of he's
kind of stuck and I'm afraid at times it
can be a security issue because he has
to run things in different versions of
PHP we've inherited this you know this
old code and so we have to keep
different versions running and try to
keep track of what will work on these
different versions I don't really like
that it seems like with JavaScript
there's not that much of an issue like
everything's always backwards compatible
at least I haven't really run into
anything like that so that's the at
least for me the only did like bad thing
I've run into with PHP and maybe there's
a way around that and I just don't know
it because I'm not I don't use PHP that
much but otherwise you know and I know
people that they make good money you
know doing things with PHP and they do
really cool stuff with it so so I don't
think there's a problem using it Harshit
says we you stream react native tomorrow
maybe it depends on how much I get done
on this project today I'm gonna work on
it
later on today so we'll see if I get it
finished and I turn it in
I may not stream about it if I if I
don't then I probably will stream so
maybe the answers may be all right so I
got through everything sorry I had to
skip over a lot of the comments and I
couldn't give as good of answers as I
normally do I guess that I'm just
running out of time so I will be back
tomorrow most likely in case I'm crazy
unless something crazy happens I'll be
around the same time around 2 p.m.
Eastern time tomorrow and thank you so
much for all your your help during this
and a lot of great discussion in a live
chat I love when that happens you're
helping each other out and helping me
out so it's just awesome but anyway I
have to go and go to a meeting now so
I'll be back tomorrow and until then
have a great day